hey everyone this is John Roca for
Collider with one of my idols number-one
idols since since the first rocky movie
that is so vest just alone with this new
film Rambo last blood I can't tell you I
want to tell you as a serviceman I
served eight years thank you so much for
this character of John Rambo he has
stood for so much in the military and
what's so interesting about this film
too is you don't shy away from the PTSD
with him and you also don't shy away
from the brutality once the turn happens
and I want to ask you about that I want
to know I'm glad you did because it's
very it's very tempting to go I had a
few more PTSD scenes and I said am i
hitting this too hard I mean I think
people get it without pounding at home
same thing with the girl we had a lot
more brutal scenes where she experiences
taking advantage of yeah and I want you
know I can see a point where people are
starting to this is too real yeah the
one thing I did not want to water down
at all is the violence because I think
violence when it's people don't really
see violence true violence the aftermath
of a hatchet attacker this and that and
when you have a character like Rambo who
has lost everything and now he's gone
into this I don't even think there's a
name for it so it was a fear of savage
primordial where there's no conscience
left as a matter of fact he wants to
desecrate the body the death is not good
enough for you for you I mean it's too
easy and war when people when we were
hit flush with a 50 millimeter you don't
exist anymore
yet I see so many of these films were a
knife in the stomach I guess and dies
yeah I could throw thirty knives in your
stomach and used as you know right I've
talked to Navy SEALs I know how many
times he just stabbed the guy well you
guys I am fronted a fellow we were
coming through the door one face to face
taboo over forty four times
and he didn't die and the only way one
hundred fifty pounds eventually I had to
shoot him and I I keep thinking man it's
not easy to kill a man yeah he wants to
stay alive that's quite a that's quite a
struggle so no I want to make it
memorable mmhmm yeah no I really do not
not overly sensational but Rambo when he
kills he it's like a trade market oh
you're never gonna
you're never gonna come you're never
gonna recover you people ever see this
they're never gonna believe their eyes
that you just can't understand what real
savagery is yeah it's 92 minutes of
absolutely beautiful brutality and as a
fan of revenge films you've taken
revenge films almost to the next level
with this one and you brought it back a
little bit more to the vibe of first
blood which I imagine that something you
know with the title you know what's
interesting too is like this is a Rambo
that's more proactive than we've seen
him before and I wonder if this was a
conscious decision by you because
normally he's has to be talking you know
yeah it's very astute you bring that up
people always think of Rambo as an
aggressor if anything he's always in
retreat absolutely always he's and he's
trained to avoid he also I never forget
someone who wrote a screenplay and how a
Rambo
well come on in the bar fight I said
never first of all he would never fight
a man face to face that's not that's
that's a different thing he is a warrior
he's stealth he's like an Indian he
kills you when you're least expecting it
and that's that's what a real warrior
does he understand I said come on butch
guns or knives you know that's a movie
kind of thing but yeah you're right he
brings into it one last question I know
we got a rep to it any last thoughts
about Rocky Balboa are we gonna see
Rocky Balboa again um right on the cusp
err I really have a good story it's
whether mmm yeah you know it's it's
rocky you see the thing is rocky outside
I'm probably don't with Crete I am dumb
okay yeah that's that's
there's nothing walking to there okay
but yeah that fist bump was the year
that's poop chow
but I have a thing that read it's
politically we would say
vital right now and it's it's it's it's
that too is it's it's right on the edge
also it deals also with the foreign
country you know you've heard a little
bit about it and they want it badly okay
yeah and it's like oh should I do this
because rocky making a rocky film and
when people like Michael I want to draw
a Creed I go and think very carefully
about this yeah if you will now have two
years of no life right and no guarantee
is going to be a hit and if you don't
find I was blessed three times with mr.
T Carl Weathers and all these are so
rare I cannot tell you John how hard it
is to find someone I can get Big Bear
huge men but some of that visually you
go he doesn't have to say a word I get
it I'm fine I wouldn't get in that ring
or Carl Weathers
there's no better film fighter as a
boxer than Carl Weathers yeah it's if
it's I have some 40 minutes of him you
know with eight millimeter it's a
miracle you know he's not a boxer yeah I
said thank God I found this guy yeah
well thing you got lightning in the
bottom with this film as well with last
blood I'm looking forward to seeing the
people's reaction to occur I absolutely
loved it
that Sylvester Stallone I'm Joan Roca
this is a life highlight for Collider go
see last blood